from the outside there's only the
slightest hint of horror
even the obvious carnage indoors doesn't
come close
this house in a village outside kiev is
where two russian soldiers allegedly
raped two ukrainian women who lived on
the same street what happened in here
one of the victims showed us the room
where she was attacked
said the soldier who raped her on this
sofa was the same age as one of her own
sons
why have you decided to speak out about
what's happened to you
the attackers had apparently been
drinking
russian troops used this place as a base
while they occupied the village in march
they forced vika to the house with her
neighbor natasha but only after they'd
shot natasha's husband dead
it was upstairs where she was then raped
we spoke to natasha by phone from
austria where she since fled with her
teenage son
a few doors down is the family home
natasha's mom and their animals are all
who remain
much of the battle damage from russia's
war is plain to see but quiet streets
like these hold a less obvious but just
as devastating trauma it's a huge
challenge for the police tasked with
investigating these crimes
in fact they've set up special teams to
gather evidence of sexual violence by
russian forces
these police officers were out on patrol
in the kiev region
the deputy interior minister said 10
rape cases are actively under
investigation
[Music]
back in the village vika has just given
evidence on camera to prosecutors
a vital step on the long road to justice
debrahing sky news in the kiev region